I think that everyone in the world could
be a nice person if they wanted to the
keywords though I want to say is if they
wanted to that said I do think that
everyone in America could benefit from
having that mathematical background in
reasoning just to help everyone make
very good decision and here I'm
distinguishing already between math as
people usually conceive of it and
decision making an analysis which is
actually what I think math is so for
example I don't think that being a math
person means that you can recite the
formulas between sines cosines tangents
and to use logarithms and Exponential's
interchangeably that's not necessarily
what I think everyone should try to
concentrate to understand the main
things to concentrate to understand are
the mathematical principles of reasoning
but let me go back to these sines
cosines and logarithms well actually if
they do have value what they are is that
they are ways to show you how these
basic building blocks of reasoning can
be used to deduce surprising things or
difficult things in some sense they're
like the historical coverages of the
triumphs of mathematics so one cannot
just talk abstractly about yes let's
talk about mathematical logic it's
actually quite useful to have case
studies or stories which which are these
these famous theorems now I actually
think that these are accessible to
everyone I think that actually one
reason mathematics is difficult to
understand it's actually because of that
network of prerequisites you see math is
one of these strange subjects for which
the concepts are chained in sequences of
dependency when you have long chains
there are very few starting points very
few things I need to memorize I don't
need to memorize for example all these
things in history such as when was the
war of 1812
well actually I know that one because
that's a math fact it was 1812 but I
can't tell you a lot of other facts
which are just purely memorized in
mathematics you're very few that you
memorize and the rest you deduce as you
go through and this chain of deductions
is actually what's critical now let me
contrast that with other subjects like
say history history doesn't have this
long chain in fact if you fully
understand the war of 1812
that's great and
it is true that that will influence
perhaps your understanding later of the
women's movement but it won't be as
absolutely prerequisite in the sense
that if you think about the concepts I
actually think that history has more
concepts than mathematics it's just that
they're spread out broader and they
don't depend on each other as strongly
so for example if you miss a week you
will miss the understanding of one unit
but that won't that won't stop you from
understanding all of the rest of the
components so that's actually the
difference between math and other
subjects in my head
math has fewer concepts but they're
change deeper and because of the way
that we usually learn when you have deep
chains it's very fragile because you
lose any one link meaning if you miss a
few concepts along the chain you can
actually be completely lost if for
example you're sick for a week or if
your mind is somewhere else for a week
you might make a hole in your
prerequisites and the way that education
often works where it's almost like
riding a train from a beginning to an
end well it's such that if you have a
hole somewhere in your track the Train
is not going to pass that hole now I
think that the way to help to address
this is to provide a way for everyone to
learn at their own pace and in fact to
fill in the holes whenever they are
sensed and I actually feel like if
everyone was able to pick up every one
of those prerequisites as necessary
filling in any gaps they have
mathematics would change from being the
hardest subject to the easiest subject I
think everyone's a math person and all
that one has to do is to go through the
chain and fill in all the gaps and
you'll understand it easier more better
than all the other subjects actually
[Music]